what's going on everyone today i want to
talk about
what it's like to live as the ultra
wealthy and so hi my name is alex uh
owner of allen prestige labs jim launch
a number of other portfolio companies
who did 120 plus million in the last
uh four years and growing and i've
learned a lot of
lessons and i want to share some of
those with you and so one of the things
is kind of understanding how the ultra
wealthy live and i want to talk about
some stuff that no one
no one i feel like no one talks about
and it's something my dad used to tell
me when i was growing up he said never
be impressed by money
and he used to say that so many times
when i was growing up and i like i
didn't really get it as much but he was
so big on it i was like hey look at that
guy he's so rich and he was just like
don't be impressed by money
and it's it's really kind of stuck with
me and so what i want to do is
kind of show you some transparent things
so that you can hopefully not be
impressed by money
so it's really easy to look ultra
wealthy
all right so i'm going to show you some
of the things that you see on instagram
um and some of the things that you know
you see around
and i'm going to break it down for you
money-wise so that hopefully it stops
impressing you
all right so we're going to talk about
private jets
we're going to talk about you know what
i'll do and at the end i'll tell you
which one i think is worth it
all right so yeah private jets let's say
you've got an exotic car
okay let's say uh what else you probably
want a penthouse
right want a penthouse what what else do
we have on our
on our dreams list all right we got
penthouse let's say you want really nice
clothes
right you want like really expensive you
know expensive clothes
all right and then let's say fancy
restaurants
all right sweet let's let's walk through
it
so this comes down to like if you're
like man i really you know my dream
lifestyle and i think this is a useful
exercise for anyone to go through
if you haven't already to find this
stuff but let's say that you travel six
times a year so every two months all
right
you go somewhere there and back average
travel at least in the us is gonna be
two hours
so if you two hour flight six times a
year all right it's there and back with
just four hours
four hours of flying six times a year
total just 24 hours all right that's 24
hours
the reason i'm defining this by hours is
because private jets uh get price per
hour
and if you're curious how much it costs
if you go through a service
you can usually get it for about four
thousand dollars an hour okay so people
don't know this
that's how much it costs all right so
that's about a hundred thousand dollars
a year
wait flying private 100 000 a year
i thought it was you had to be a super
duper millionaire no not really
um it's 100 grand a year now do i think
that's really expensive for flights
when the alternative to that is for for
for six flights could be uh you know
maybe you know if you did first class
you'd be maybe spending
six grand you know at worst if you did
it last minute you'd spend like 10 grand
so 10 times the price for an alternative
well
that's the alternative price all right
consider it the next one
exotic cars all right so i'll give you a
range here but you can pretty much get a
really nice car for a thousand dollars a
month
like a very very very nice car if you
want like a rolls-royce
you know one of the most expensive cars
anywhere and you're releasing it
you would spend you know 4 500 months
you know 4 500 bucks a month
all right so that's 4 000 a month
which is about 50 000 a year
right all right next one
penthouse so if you this kind of depends
on like unless you're in a major city
but if you're not in a major city which
is what most of the
the ig influencers will try and
influence you with
um you can get a really nice place for
five thousand dollars a month
in just about every market that's not
new york you know la
you know it's like maybe miami and
sometimes even the nice place my name is
like 10 grand a month
right but you know what let's let's
level up let's let's live a little bit
so we'll say 10
000 a month all right really really
really nice place
all right so that's 120k a year all
right
and then finally expensive clothes
believe it or not are some of the
cheapest things
that are out there because i mean you
buy your gucci belt which is 500 bucks
you buy your
your gucci shoes which are another 600
bucks
and then you know you want to buy a
handful 100 t-shirts
okay so i mean you're spending what like
3 000 a year you know on clothes which
is not nearly as much as you'd think
right
and then fancy restaurants let's say you
go out to
date night once a week and you drop 400
on a really nice dinner really really
nice dinner i'm trying we're living it
up here right
so it's 600 bucks a month times 12. i
don't want to do the math there let's
say it's 20k
all right so this lifestyle and this is
the
this is the i mean we're talking the
ultra ultra ultra wealthy lifestyle this
isn't just like um
i'm a millionaire this is like i'm a
super duper wealthy person right i mean
look at all this stuff we've got
we've got lamborghinis pen houses we're
only wearing uh you know designer
clothes
we've we travel with private jets we go
to fancy restaurants we do all of that
stuff how much does it actually cost
right it costs 100 grand 150
270 about 300 grand a year all right
300 grand a year
so that's that's it that's the dream
number and i have so many people were
like
i need to make a zillion dollars right
well after taxes you need to make 300
grand
so you're looking at 500 ish 1000 a year
550 is what you need to make and that is
a top that's top one percent
but this is so stupid
um as someone who literally has done all
of these things uh let me let me give
you some insight into some of the stuff
that i've discovered
one flying private is actually really
nice
but it's it's wildly expensive and i
still feel guilty for it
exotic car definitely not worth it i
have two
and like i they're so not worth it at
all
like seriously not worth it at all the
incremental enjoyment that i get
compared to
driving like a an old prius or a pickup
truck is
is inconsequential if anything you get
used to it within like
a week or two and honestly the only
reason i got this is because i was on a
podcast with brad lee if you guys know
him
and he was like dude you're so cheap
he's like just go you know like
just get the car because my wife and i
split a car until not that long ago
and he was like dude you make so much
money just go get the darn car so i was
like all right i won't be a cheap ass
and so i got the car and now i totally
regret it but
you know it is what it is so hopefully
you can learn from that mistake
that being said what i'm gonna do is
also i'll walk through percentage of
income
like for perspective if i can do this
all of this stuff off of one week's
income
it what do you do the next week right
and so that's why increasing your income
is so important because
all of this stuff's actually really easy
to achieve um
and so that's why i don't think you
should be like taking huge advice from
people
because get you know getting a business
to do you know 80 000
a month and you know taking home 40
pretty much just affords you this
lifestyle that's it like now mind you
knock out private jet flying
and you know make a reasonable penthouse
instead of a ten thousand dollar a month
penthouse which is
is a really nice place right then just
like that we took out
half the cost of this lifestyle so now
we're down to 150 000
right it's like okay well then i could
still look like a super and i still have
my exotic car
still have expensive clothes still eat
at fancy restaurants and that's on 150
grand a year
right and so my my biggest takeaways
here
are or that i that i hope people take
away is
like the people who have the most money
honestly all of this stuff is a very
very small percentage of their income
and so don't let this be the reason that
you listen to someone because
there are people who live like this and
that's 100 of their income
and those are people you should not
listen to for advice on money
right like in my opinion the only reason
you should ever
get to this part is is when you're you
know it's you're living this is
this is less than 10 of what you make
that's my that's my opinion
less than ten percent of what you make
you save ninety percent all right
and so overall the that that's my that's
my big message is that i have i have
done all of these things
i am not currently wearing fancy clothes
i'm wearing jean shorts
and a t-shirt that my aunt gave me for
christmas
fancy restaurants this is something that
i do with layla and i
actually feel like i get a good return
on our date night
but not on the fact that it's a fancy
restaurant i enjoy applebee's
cheesy factory bj's and chili's
and chipotle honestly just as much as i
enjoy
the fancy restaurant i think the value
of the fancy restaurant is that you
dress up
more so than the actual food and
experience and i've had the 500 steaks
and all that stuff and honestly like a
really good double meat chipotle bowl
hard to beat fajitas and chips at
chili's hard to beat cheesecake factory
cheesecake
hard to beat pizookia bjs no one has
anything on their desserts right
and so what's interesting is that having
now done these exotic things
especially like cars and experiences
you'd be surprised that a lot of times i
think the best quality
having now tasted all of these things
the best quality comes from the stuff
that tends to be the biggest mass market
because they do the most product testing
and so recently i rented a i think i
rented a chevy
suburban we were traveling somewhere and
the interface was so much easier to deal
with than my bentley's interface
it was so simple i plugged my phone in
it worked automatically it was just like
it was such a dream
compared to this thing that's a 350 000
car because they only make
you know a handful of them so they don't
have nearly the product testing
and they put all these gizmos in it that
are impossible to figure out how to use
and so don't don't be don't be persuaded
by this stuff all right try
this is just my two cents you can take
whatever you want from it but this has
just been my experience with all of
these things
restaurants i like that the the cheaper
ones better expensive clothes
i clothes i get nothing from so
personally i think i have some shirts
that are awesome
but the mass majority of them are less
than 30
the penthouse thing i don't think you
should spend a lot of money on where you
live
personally i think if you look at your
primary residence as an investment if
you can
and live in something that would be an
investment income uh
type property then i think it makes
sense like the places that really make
sense is like if you can live in a
duplex and run out the other spot you
live for free and you're gonna pre
you're appreciating the assets you have
that stuff makes a lot of sense to me
and you have to pick figure out what
your trade-offs are but if this is the
absolute
ultra wealthy you know uh a lifestyle
do you know what ultra ultra wealthy is
because i'll tell you what it is right
now it's 30 million or more
30 million to a billion in investable
assets
well if you have 30 million dollars in
investable assets that's the bottom
range of alternate high net worth then
if you're gaining even 10
a year you're making 3 million a year
right on your money just your money
making money
and so just your passive income is
10 times greater than what it costs to
live this way and so in that instance
it kind of makes sense right or it's
like if you want to do it do it
but i'll tell you this of the people
that i know were ultra wealthy
not kind of wealthy not high net worth
which is 5 to 30 or just
um or millionaire right which is one to
five
the people who have that stuff uh who
are the highest that i know almost
all of them i've had these conversations
with them have come to the same
conclusion which is
almost none of this stuff is worth it
and so you get there you try the fruit
and you realize
this is just not worth it so if i can
hopefully save somebody a couple hundred
grand
who does get there then try and avoid
this stuff
that's that's my two cents so that's
what that's what i have for you if
you've if you never experienced this
stuff or don't know how much it cost
this is how much this stuff costs in the
real world i do think you should
spend less than if you can uh less than
10
of what you make because if you can
spend less than 10 what you make
then it means that honestly within two
to five years you can live
completely free of anything because
your wealth is a ratio between your
expenses and your income it is not a
number
that's the thing everyone messes up it's
an expense it's a ratio of income to
expenses
that is what wealth is and so if your
income to expense ratio
is ten to one you are very wealthy so
whether you live on thirty thousand
dollars a year and you make three
hundred thousand a year that is a very
wealthy person they're
extremely extremely well set up they
have no stress because they have so much
more
than they need and so that's what i
think the key comes down to is
having so much more than you need and
the happiness equation if you guys don't
know what it actually is
it's not uh when i get x i will be happy
that's uh that's not the right one
the right one is haves
over once
and if you can get your wants to zero
then it doesn't matter what you have on
top
equals infinity and so as much as
everyone
likes to chase the the top number to
compensate for the fact that they want
these things
if you can simply decrease the desire
you will increase the abundance in your
life
and by extension your your income to
expense ratio which is what will build
your wealth and give you the freedom you
want so
anyways this has been a little
experience of mine that i hope you find
valuable and hopefully you don't have to
make
some of these lovely mistakes that i
have keeping awesome lots of love i'll
catch you guys soon
bye